look at the rulings that we're getting
right now on the election fraud struck
these these are
trump federal judiciary appointees that
are coming back and saying like
listen man you are insane these
affidavits are crazy
there's there's no joke at this like
there's no i'm i can't believe the
defense i'm seeing for
for what's going on in in these trump
lawsuits trump put out this 46 minute
video and i listened to it and i
i'm i'm not gonna i'm not gonna mince
words trump did not present his case
well they they talked through the same
like i think i it was a 4600 on facebook
i think i watched the same video usually
there's talk through the same like seven
affidavits every single time
there's there's legitimate there's
there's way more affidavits
there's way more articulate individuals
presenting evidence and for some reason
the trump team is not bringing together
well maybe it's not as legitimate as
some alternative media suggests it might
be
no i think i think the issue is when you
hear trump do a 46 minute video
and he can't actually calmly cite matt
brainard
and he points to a picture and says look
at that how does that make sense i'm
like
you're not giving me an articulate
breakdown of why the issue is why is it
that in
all of these federal cases where these
are being brought and the breaches are
actually
no the trump campaign has three oh maybe
the trump campaign personally
you can't you can't tell me that some
random people filing a lawsuit is
reflective about trump
you can't tell me that an affidavit
alone is like valid evidence that like
something horrible has happened
it is testimony as evidence
well okay well in that case there's a 13
year old that has an affidavit out there
meaning they've signed it i've
apparently approached you that trump
raped her that was retracted though
sure but a lot of these affidavits are
also under scrutiny
as well so it's not proof evidence is
not proof that's right so
but i'm just saying that like just
because there's an affidavit doesn't
mean that this absolutely happened so
for instance sure when giuliani brought
the uh
miss johnson what was the name of the
indian lady um that testified for so
long you know in front of michigan
um it was like johanna jones or
something uh but like she came and she
gave a lot of the exact same testimony
that had already been stricken down in
court
so for instance she talked about being
like the tfe voting center and she was
like the election officials told me not
to verify signatures and i don't know
why they were doing that
when the judge went through it he was
like well that's because that wasn't
your job they were verified what they've
got to do let me see a question what
what's the
what's the point of a of an observer
what is the point of an observer
yeah i it super depends on on every
individual area i would imagine so
uh broadly speaking probably to observe
like to observe what
um the the matching of signatures on
ballots or whatever
so opening and closing would you agree
with the judge who shot down trump's
this actual trump lawsuit
saying that so long as an observer is
somewhere in the building it counts as
legal
observation it probably depends on the
precedent set by previous by prior cases
doesn't that sound bad faith like what
sounds bad faith to me is that all of
this stuff was brought up after it was
shown that trump had lost the election
where were all of these complaints on
election night
like complaints that the that that
observers weren't allowed in
complaining about the dominion voting
systems they were they were all over
twitter they absolutely were not yeah
there were a few random let me just cite
chamberlain who was on the ground
walking going throughout philly's a
lawyer taking posting in photos and
videos
people were complaining about being
booted but you gotta understand a lot of
these people aren't on social media they
don't know what to do it's not about
just being on social media because part
of the reasons why these federal judges
are throwing these cases out so
specifically regards the indian lady um
because on election night none of these
people were actually complaining it
wasn't until giuliani went around so
listening affidavits
days later or weeks later asking people
actually asking for we're asking like
yeah
are you a witness do you have evidence
yes i do please come forward that sounds
like the normal thing you have to do
doesn't it sound a little bit strange
imagine if the judge was complaining
none of these no it doesn't complain
imagine if it's uh
imagine if a judge said we're not going
to use this witness testimony because
the witness to the murder only came
forward a month later after cop found
him
that's that's ridiculous it was it was
more like all this widespread wrongdoing
was apparently being conserved
nobody but they weren't why didn't they
go through any of the proper channels to
report any of this
like what probably they did i think they
just don't know this like matt brainerd
specifically said he gave his
information to
a district attorney i might not know
this but none of the federal judges that
have reviewed these cases
i apparently know this either because
that is one of the most why these get
shot down it absolutely is what you
so do you know what the basis of the of
the pennsylvania lawsuit was
uh which one trump's got one
pennsylvania what is the basis for that
one that vote observers weren't allowed
to actually observe the ballot process
the counting process okay
the court ruled that so long as an
observer was somewhere present in the
building
whether they were allowed to actually
observe as meaningless because the
election code doesn't specify distance
that is one of the most insane things
i've ever heard come out of a person's
mouth
we know why vote observers exist because
we have photos from bush v gore of
people staring
side by side up at the ballot arguing
over whether or not it was bush or gore
wasn't one of the pennsylvania cases
that they won the small one wasn't one
of the cases they won was when
the somebody related to the pennsylvania
election stuff said that we were going
to allow people to vote up to a certain
length in time
or it was something where like what they
had said wasn't necessarily bad but the
judge came out and said listen even
though that's not really bad it's not in
your it's not the proof of your job to
do that you're not allowed to do that
and i think that was the one case that
they won and i think that was in
pennsylvania i don't think that was a
trump campaign
that might not have been their lawsuit
that was the one one lawsuit in
pennsylvania for a small handle
but like if the code doesn't specify it
or if it's explicitly not specified
then i i mean like what case do you have
what standing do you have there then
also judges interpret the law right
so when the law says as per election
code observers shall be there to observe
the vote tabulating process we know that
the spirit of that law the reason why we
have it is so that you can have
scrutineers
making sure someone isn't going trump
trump trump so no no no that was biden
but they put people way far back behind
plexiglas walls
and the trump campaign said why were we
not allowed to observe
why should they challenge any of these
laws before election night
because the law there's no ruling on it
first of all do you understand what
injury and fact is
that you need some uh there has to be
damage so when the trump campaign did
sue beforehand
the supreme court reserved their right
to judge uh to issue later on
they sued over mail in voting and the
court this is not this is a totally
unrelated thing now
there's a bunch of different lawsuits
there's a bunch of different sure but
now we're talking about like i'm talking
very specifically about we can talk
about the demanding voters or more
specifically
sure you're about the observer stuff
right if this all was codified in state
law
and the law is there and we've held you
through our elections we just had
suggestions two
you can't sue on the basis of clarifying
what the law really means
until you have injuries it doesn't have
to be suing believe it or not there are
other ways in this country to change
laws there are legislations both in the
state and federal level they can change
these laws you don't need the suited
changes
if we pass a law saying you have a right
to observe as i count votes right
do you reasonably believe you have a
right to look at me and the votes
why why did anyone think a judge was
going to say no nope it didn't specify
that you had to actually see the vote
so long as you're in the building come
on man that's unreasonable you're saying
come on okay
trump for months because they knew that
they were going to get destroyed on the
mail-in ballots trump for months was
calling out the mail-in ballots
and guess what he was doing that far
before
any lawsuits had to be followed years
ago far before any injury occurred
okay they were calling these out why
didn't they call out anything related to
voting observers
the reason why is because they know it's
all bs no i know that this fraud didn't
happen
one million percent because because if i
was somebody that had a massive vested
interest and making sure that these
elections weren't going to be rigged
i wouldn't be calling this out after joe
biden hold on
it's probably something that you would
have brought up beforehand you can't be
serious that you think
it is reasonable that so long as an
observer is somewhere in the building
that counts as observing the vote
counting process you can't be serious
that you think that the only reason that
they would challenge this is because
like well now they've lost the election
and now this is the first time they've
noticed it these laws have been in place
in some ways for decades and in previous
elections people were allowed to
actually look at the ballots
no one knew that this time that the
these precincts specifically pittsburgh
and allegheny county and pennsylvania
were going to bar
observers and they'd have to sue over it
okay why
prediction not taking a comics do you
think they're going to win any of these
lawsuits in a meaningful way
not like there were four ballots and a
mailing thing or not do you think that
they're actually going absolutely not
why not first of all when a judge says
did you have observers in the building
and the republican says
the amount of observers in the building
was a non-zero number
but we were not given meaningful access
to the votes and the judge says well
according to the election code
it doesn't specify the distance by which
you can observe therefore
you have no you have no grounds to sue
that is
clearly bad faith if trump is going to
lose
it's going to be for two reasons many of
these judges and one judge even said
this
if you think i will he said you can't
expect me to rule in such a way that
would disenfranchise millions of voters
that's
that's absurd i can't do that that's not
all he said
no no i'm just i'm bringing up that
point supposedly there was a very
important second part to that and he
said i can't do that with no evidence he
said that
one would think that if somebody was
coming to me to disenfranchise even one
vote that they would be coming with a
very strong case of lots of evidence but
let alone millions of votes to bring
such a shoddy case built on poor legal
arguments with no evidence or shoddy
evidence that
that was the full quote for that so the
point i'm saying is
there's an unwillingness to take such a
massive and
unprecedented move in a court without
evidence there's there is evidence there
isn't though just because the judge said
without evidence doesn't mean there's no
evidence that's just one judge but
people have gone through
so many of these affidavits here's did
you watch are we talking about trump's
lawsuits or random
i guess i'm not i don't know one million
percent the distinction between only
trump's lawsuit
and all of the other ones that have been
brought up people people have been
rooting and cheering for sydney powell
and look at what tucker carl having with
tucker carlson when he was like where's
the evidence they ripped him apart they
left fox news
and now many trump supporters are going
after sydney powell because they're
saying she's actually a democrat trying
to undermine the republican party
of course the craziest thing because
anybody that's not locked up with daddy
trump is immediately castigating no
and well for sure but people are so
adamantly behind sidney powell and lynn
wood it's
it's crazy like when when i tweet i
tweeted that it sounds like
sydney powell's getting her information
from conspiracy forms oh people start
tweeting me like crazy
and they've been making fun of me like
oh how dare you now what trump she's
contradicting trump
like that stuff i keep saying over and
over again you come out and want to
claim that
this company was founded in venezuela
smartmatic and then sequoia and all this
stuff
may be true that's totally fine but bro
you need extraordinary evidence for
extraordinary claims
when we're talking about a judge in
pennsylvania and the lawsuit wasn't
about fraud
it's another thing that the left keeps
doing trump has specific lawsuits
pertaining to the
validity of mail-in voting and absentee
voting deadlines etc
so in these court cases the judge will
ask for a simple clarification are you
alleging fraud no your honor we're not
i'll take a clip of that and say aha
this proves it trump is saying there's
no fraud and the lawsuit isn't claiming
it
yeah he didn't sue over fraud because
that requires
long-term then was because some of these
judges were trying to figure out what
standing they even had then to be there
because because initially it felt like
the thing that i feel when i read the
differences between what's what's being
reported in these court cases versus
what julian comes out and says giuliani
sounds like he's alleging some massive
election fraud absolutely but then when
it comes to them talking in front of a j
it's like the meme with the
the little dog and then the like the
shredded dog and the shredded dog is
like giuliani in front of the camera's
alleging fraud
election conspiracy and then when he
gets in front of a child he's like okay
i'm not saying fraud but like i don't
think this lady was allowed to be in an
area where she was supposed to be and
it's over like the smallest minutiae
ever and they don't even have good
evidence what they're doing
i think i think it's fair to say that
the trump the trump campaign is not
delivering
in terms of the legal process by which
they go after fraud 100
i also think it's fair to say that the
legal strategy over challenging
voting systems and ballots is a legal
strategy and that's
i wish that that strategy if it's
something that they so deeply cared
about
i wish that they would have done that
prior to the actual election no but you
don't understand man
how could they have known that the
observers wouldn't have been allowed
maybe they could have specified it in
the code
it seems like trump has every other
conspiracy theory in his head about how
he's going to be disenfranchised you
don't think having people observing the
vote would have been like
the law existed though they had them
they didn't specify
i'm giving you a lot here because i
haven't read the exact verbiage because
i'm willing to bet that when i go back
home and actually read through the case
it's going to be more than just like
they had to be anywhere in the building
but literally
my guess is going to be that it's
probably been consistent with state laws
over all prior elections and it hasn't
been a big deal before but now people
are just really mad
because of the massive increase in in
voters for democrats on the mainland
ballots
and that's why everybody's losing their
mind over it let me ask you should we
have
scrutineers people who look at the
ballots as they're being counted from
both parties or even a third party
i don't know how these elections
remember that that sounds normally what
they do yeah it sounds like it'd be
is it okay that this time they didn't do
that i don't know if that's the case i
don't think in the majority of places
that is the case where it wasn't no no
no no specifically the pennsylvania suit
yes specifically in some philly and
elegant account
yeah so you have these videos coming out
where people are standing 100 feet away
binoculars
and they're like i literally can't see
anything one of the most important
lessons i've learned in my life is to
never believe anything i've ever seen in
a twitter video just so many things i
don't know what what the video what time
it's foreign
what was it i don't know multiple
stories somebody else that i'd heard
just recently say something about like
um
like all of these uh votes are being
reported by machine like you don't see
people walking around voting
we did literally on election night you
saw people like delivering votes and
stuff to
to county houses and stuff or bringing
them from other counties like yeah like
when it comes to videos i don't trust
any of that on the internet without like
a greater story context surrounding
because anybody can take one video of
any sworn effort look at this
sure swarming so sworn affidavits in
combination with the videos
sworn after david is interesting and and
them saying
we can't see we can't actually observe
the votes so
a big portion of what julian is bringing
forward right now in in michigan and his
other places
is that all of these a lot of these
people who are coming forward saying
they're not allowed to actually observe
the vote count so when you have
unprecedented rule changes
no excuse mail in voting which in the
instance of pennsylvania now a judge
recently issued an opinion citing that
it seems very likely
the the plaintiffs will win on the
merits that this is unconstitutional
the supreme court shut it down on a
narrow ruling that it was too late to
to sue on this you know even though they
just found out they brought it out
they just found out about the law they
just found out about the acceptance of
late mail and voting that it was in
violation of the constitution
why they didn't see it initially you
know what it sounds like it sounds like
they lost and now they're going back and
trying it certainly does
okay absolutely agree with you which
makes it hard to believe in good faith
but but that's not that's not the legal
system would work well according to some
of these judges that's explicitly how
the legal so for instance in some of
these rulings
the judge explicitly will say the fact
that she didn't follow any of the chain
of command or the fact that this person
didn't report any of this on election
night
is very damaging to their credibility
why would it matter if the lawsuit was
now or later when they weren't asking to
do anything to this current election
what the reason why it matters is
because if these things are happening
and they're only being reported
retroactively it seems like it's
interesting it wouldn't happen if i
didn't lose it it would
have divided winning rather than to any
actual but if it wouldn't have an impact
on the election then
it's irrelevant what do you mean the
lawsuit wasn't asking to do anything to
the current election they asked the
courts to issue their advice on relief
meaning
perhaps in the future we won't do no
excuse mail in voting the supreme court
said
it's too late to sue for this dismissed
with uh with
with prejudice meaning these people
can't bring these cases up uh ever again
what's interesting is that the lower
court ruling was that it would have been
detrimental
to several of the plaintiffs who
actually won their elections mike kelly
won
and then sued saying we didn't realize
that the republicans passed an
unconstitutional law
and the the judge actually issued an
opinion saying as this would be you not
realize somebody passed the law
they realized the law was passed but
many people didn't know
that it was unconstitutional what
changed did they read a tweet or
whatever they write the constitution
no after election they didn't do that
when the law was being passed isn't that
part of like your
job as a legislator i'd be willing to
bet there was somebody who was looking
at
what's going on what can we do and the
motivation was very much
trump is losing this however the lawsuit
wasn't brought by trump
it was brought actually by a guy who won
and
several other people as well as a guy
who lost so it was a mixed bag and they
weren't asking for the election to be
thrown out they were asking for the
courts to
advise on what relief could be sean
parnell sat here
just you know couple a week ago and he
said i don't want anyone to be
disenfranchised
i don't want uh i'm not saying this vote
has to be thrown out this election has
to be thrown out
we all thought this was constitutional
i'm just asking for maybe
the court will advise us maybe they'll
say hey this we need a constitutional
amendment so from this point forward
we're going to say no to this you know
excuse me and voting moving forward and
then you get a constitutional amendment
you know what's really crazy about it
when the when the gop was passing uh the
pennsylvania gop was passing act 77
which is no excuse mail in voting they
actually started the process to amend
the constitution and halfway through
stopped
changed some wording and then it got
passed signed off on by governor so this
is a bipartisan
approval most people didn't realize what
had happened wait
that doesn't sound like a bad thing on
his face at all if you were going to
pass something and then
you realize it was going to be
unconstitutional so you got to change
the constitution when you realize well
hold on if we reform some of this bill
no no no
no no you said reform i said they
changed some of the words
okay so laws are the words that make the
laws let's
let's let's not play semantic games it's
not a semantic game
when you say change some words like i
can change some words and make anything
anything else what do you mean by that
so let's let's let's not place them into
games
let's define it when the constitution
says absentee ballots require specific
excuses to be allowed
okay and the law they initially
presented was no excuse absentee they
changed absentee to mail
okay that's the that's it are there an
entirely different set of provisions
that come in under mail-in ballots
versus absentee is there a whole
different part of their state
legislature that has a different way of
dealing with
the same thing the exact same thing and
that's why the judge in the lower court
ruled
the plaintiffs will will will likely be
successful on the merits
and then the the higher court said we're
not ruling on the merits we don't know
it's just too late okay well sounds like
they should have brought it up
beforehand then they're going to the
supreme court
okay and i'll be interested in going to
the supreme court so one of the one of
the issues that i have when people keep
saying affidavits out of david savage is
that
on the first hand is it feels like
somebody's sliding down a mountain
grabbing branches or whatever as he's
going down
like initially we're grabbing all the
mail and ballots are voted fraud then we
were
saying you know um uh we've got the
dominion voting machines are made in
venezuela and then somehow hugh shabas
is coming back to life to blah blah blah
no no no stop stop stop first of all the
dominion stuff is nuts in my opinion
i know that's crazy i can't believe
these machines existed for so long and
no one said anything about it that's not
your election
2006 cnn reported on it what did they
report they reported that they were
completely insecure and there was a
bunch of problems and all this stuff
and one of the things specifically that
they reported is stuff like a lack of
paper trail or no ability to audit these
machines
which has been some of the stuff that
has been corrected and fixed and almost
every single state that allows these
machines to function hold on you said
hugo chavez came back to life
sure no one's argued that okay i'm just
hearing chavez's name a lot really
because
smartmatic there was a there's a
wikileaks release from 2010
this was this has been on the internet
for over a decade cablegate
where they say in 2010 hugo chavez
was providing you know resources to a
group of individuals in venezuela who
are the principal owners
and if you travel through all these
different shell companies you find it
originated in
venezuela that's where that hugo chavez
comes from sure i feel like the argument
that hugo chavez came back to life is an
attempt to
ignore what's actually being presented
well i'm attempting to make the people
sound insane because they are
to assume that there's some wider play
by some other country
why are you doing that you don't have to
be ridiculous you don't need to
i think well because for me because i do
a lot of humor so i think it's funny
when people vote
so much to try to scare people into
thinking that some machines are stealing
our election
but to say like this narrative that
confuses the actual argument from people
wait what is the actual argument the
actual argument
is that going back uh you know a decade
plus
going back 20 years there was a series
of companies
that were started with the express
purpose of being able to hide
through audits that votes were
manipulated there is a company
smartmatic
that was involved in this and has ties
to venezuela as per diplomatic cables
that were like 10 years ago so we've
known about this for a long time why
did the dhs and the department i'm not
saying that's true
i'm sure it's true but it's ridiculous
crazy there's
there's a difference between what these
people are actually arguing and
coming out and saying he was shadows
returning the great so on the level of
raised dominion voting machines if any
of this was true
it would be the largest political news
story related to elections
in the past hundreds you trust the media
to report something like this
this is like pulitzer prize-winning
related they won pulitzer's for the
russia gate stuff
sure there was a lot of good reporting
and a lot of credible indictments that
came out of that unlike the benghazi and
the email hearings
but regardless i'm just saying that like
this level of election fraud would be
like an
unimaginable what were the what were the
indictments
related to russia um so one had to do
with the internet research agency which
was funded by
the gremlin which had a whole bunch of
fun but those were foreigners not trump
and not trump
correct yeah um yeah there were no
indictments related specifically to
trump's cabinet although we did get some
indictments kind of like arrest
yeah so the manafort stuff came out of
that um flynn got caught lying to the
fbi
um although daddy trump pardoned him um
cohen went down for
uh the new york related stuff and the
elections you know the crazy thing about
the manafort stuff is you know they
found out about that
what did they find out about you you
know that how they find out found out
about manafort
i read a lot of weird stuff to the
political workforce some guy's office
and they found a ledger that was like
written
on a piece of paper whatever meant for
owing to money and so they didn't report
to the state department but go ahead
politico reported that ukrainian
operatives were trying to sabotage trump
and so they sent documents to a dnc
operative
and then she you know passed it along
saying here we got some dirt go after
them and they did
so it was political it was you know
political so all of manafort's charges
were just 100
dollars saying they found out about a
lot of his documents because it was
passed off for political reasons
if something should be surprising to
anybody sure i don't know how that
absolves i didn't say i did i said it's
interesting that
you know we've got ukraine stepping up
we've got this you know political battle
people are trying to go after each other
yeah i'm sure people are trying to send
people dirt about other leaders all the
time we have
assange and wikileaks and they're doing
all of that for a long time for the left
um we also as a result of all those
indictments found out a lot about how
the um
how the dnc was penetrated via the
spirit fishing stuff by the goose of a
2.0 hacker and everything we
saw a lot of them in the end as well
some people should not be
some people don't use computers and a
lot of people with import with access to
really important information
you know but uh but let's not yeah
they'll be real go back to the voter
stuff yeah
the point is on the pia on the
pennsylvania point that i'm bringing up
is
we had a serious conundrum in terms of
voter observation
it is i think widely accepted that we
should have
observers making sure that people aren't
falsifying the vote count
do you agree if the pennsylvania court
just ruled that's not the case
should we change it so that is the case
i would have to see the on the specific
ruling for that argument because more
often than that when people cite these
usually they're
sure some key let's just say i
personally i think you should probably
have people observing the election i
can't think of a reason offhand why you
wouldn't that doesn't make sense to me
but i would have to read into why they
made the ruling they did so
check it out the issue would be then if
the
the judge made this ruling on the
grounds the election code doesn't
specify distance
i mean then why wouldn't say trump 2024
just be like
we're cleared we got we got a ruling
from the court we know what we can do
now and you can't sue us with unless
you're you have a syria
unless you have injury in fact therefore
when it comes time to election all
republicans bar all democrats and we
can't lose
we can write down whatever numbers we
want if you want so yeah go for it
so it's a serious threat to our election
integrity it could potentially be yeah
and if somebody were to bring it up in
that manner i'd believe them when they
said that but right now it just feels
like republicans doing anything they can
to try to flip the election results
i think yes 100 and i think the
democrats
they didn't i don't think they tried to
flip the results in 2016 for the most
part there were there was a whole lot of
the hillary can still win stuff and
hillary conceded the next day
but absolutely not even remotely similar
uh
it's remotely similar i would say it's
maybe like the way that antarctica is
remotely close to like please do you see
the videos of celebrities saying the
electoral college must
vote for hillary clinton do you think
there's a difference well i'm sorry they
didn't say that they said between
celebrities saying something and the
president of the united states trying to
undermine the election
that's why i'm saying these aren't
remotely similar yes under mine see
that's that's that's framing
well it's when you say 2016 trump said
millions of illegals voted he started
that with no evidence that's undermining
the integrity of election
and then in 2020 he's saying that there
was widespread election fraud
that literally no agency no other
credible person is backed up saved for
the melting hit of giuliani like no one
else is backing up on this
his own dhs turned on him on this with
his own appointee
his own attorney general the sword and
shield what did he say barr
came out and said that as of right now
there is no evidence of widespread
election fraud
um wait wait there's more of that quote
what else that would have changed the
outcome of the election out in the
election okay
to date we have not seen evidence that
on a scale that would have changed
what else did he say too what else he
also said that they looked into the
dominion machines and based on their
analysis of it they didn't see any
evidence
also that those machines were fully
voted i think the dominion stuff is is
over the top look you got
you got brian kemp and brian uh was it
with brian kemp is his name right
and raffensberger okay are they both
brian was it brad ravensburg i'm mixing
their names up or something
but these are republicans i don't think
there's a grand conspiracy where members
of like
the trump supporting republican
georgians are like ah now our chance
but people really believe it yeah they
do i think for one
partially because a lot of people play
into it you do as well right how do i
play into it
when you're tweeting i just straight up
agreed and said it was nuts sure i know
but a lot of the it feels like a lot of
your rhetoric gives a lot of credence or
credibility to a lot of the lawsuits are
challenged
you know like how the election is being
like i like the fact that you're willing
to say that you think that the elect do
you do you think that the election the
majority of the election was legit
that maybe there were a few but you
think for the results stand
i think what people need to realize too
is you don't need widespread fraud alter
the outcome of an election
you know you would no you don't you you
need maybe one person in four key
districts
absolutely not or one person with a usb
stick absolutely not that's not how
these work
it is it absolutely actually was in
vegas at def con when they hacked the
voting machines
i watch them do it i don't know what
voting machines they hacked but
hacking hacking one machine or hacking a
series of machines is a lot different
than the step-by-step process that goes
through
tabulating results or pointing them but
they all go in the machine right
sure but there's also paper trails
behind all of these votes as well and
they didn't
did did they do a hard signature audit
they didn't i don't know if they did
that they did they
they did a risk they have their yeah
their risk assessment audits but there
is a paper trail behind every single
thing but now the problem is saying
well for some of the ballots that were
taken to the mail and things they've
been separated from
they destroyed the verify or whatever
that's a problem
they destroyed so with the observers in
pennsylvania they destroyed the secrecy
envelopes
so now it's like what do we do they
destroyed them before anybody could
could check to see if they were legit
why would they do that
but you so you believe the election is
legitimate as it stands but maybe there
are some things we could fix going
forward because that's a stat that's a
stance i could maybe
i would say as of right now i said this
uh and i got ragged on hard for it on
september 7th uh i sat down like on the
eighth i think
no no no it wasn't the eighth it was the
ninth cause i took a day off because i
was like
everything's crazy uh the the the simple
solution is trump got oceans eleven
that if the the cheating as as i would
frame it is the mass changing of rules
well before the election using covet as
a pretext when
act 77 was even passed in october the
democrats did
everything in their power within the
system to give themselves advantages
they were going door-to-door they were
doing democracy in the park they were
doing illegal
uh democracy in the park was illegal uh
the vote raffles that we just saw emerge
all these videos
through all these different swing states
was also illegal there's no evidence
as of right now there are i should say
there's not enough have you ever been
charged over this democracy in the park
stuff or
there was uh i would say not yet i don't
know okay but i will say there was one
person so far charged with 135 counts
related to
basically getting infirm people to vote
and signing off documents for them
there's currently uh a case going to the
the uh
the uh i think the district attorney in
pennsylvania
where they found several thousand
ballots all filled out in the same
handwriting for joe biden
in the names of elderly people in
various nursing homes so
this stuff happened it exists can i say
that this is the the reason why joe
biden went i can't
so i'm not gonna i do not agree with
trump when he says
i lost due to a regulation and
widespread fraud i say well there's
evidence of fraud
to the scale that would have generated a
flipping of the election i would say
no there was impropriety that would have
changed the outcome of the election
but what we're talking about with that
with trump's lawsuit in pennsylvania is
disqualifying 682 000 votes
because they weren't observed as they
were counted and as giuliani said mickey
mouse could have filled them out
that is not fraud that is them saying we
should disqualify these votes in an
attempt to win because they weren't
allowed to observe them
i think it's a problem that people
weren't allowed to observe them properly
i don't know that disenfranchising the
state
is the appropriate you know path forward
that's mostly a gribble shirt i would
say for
life pro tip for people in the future or
anybody um either playing video games
with friends or trying to run a country
if you have severe problems with the way
that rules are it's usually good to try
to change the rules before you lose
otherwise everybody's going to look at
you sideways wondering if you actually
care about the rules or if you're just
trying to get them changed
but they're not trying to change the
rules well in terms of like saying well
in terms of specifying the distance or
in terms of like having observers in a
certain area or whatever it sounds like
they want to refine these girls to
that hasn't gone to the succeed court
yet uh however there's a there's a trump
supporting lawyer
a friend of mine named will chamberlain
he said he's it's not going there sure
the supreme court he said
it was it was it was uh on appeal so you
saw that court case where the trump
appointee was like get out of here
okay they appealed it and they uh that
case was them appealing just to have the
right to amend the argument in the first
place and they said
get out of here so well if this is the
same one that i'm thinking the reason
why they told them to get out of there
is because i think that this was a
giuliani this was a trump case right it
was yeah they'd amended this case like
five or six times and i think
giuliani showed up they wanted to amend
it for a second time that was it
and so what i wish i remember exactly
what this was but i know that i watched
there was one because there was a legal
analysis video of one of these that
julianne got thrown out of court because
they they had moved
different lawyers on and off of this
case so much and then they'd pushed it
right and they tried to amend the case
so many times
that eventually the lawyer was like hey
you know why they changed a joke like
get out
i know you're not gonna say because of
death threats yeah the
the the the uh a bunch of high-profile
verified leftists uh the lincoln project
posted the phone numbers
of lawyers and then within a day they
said please judge let us leave the case
like that's that's i mean that's the
only reasonable
that's the only the reason they did it
the judges quit the case after being
threatened and harassed so i've had
unfortunately a lot of bad uh
experiences with people higher education
that makes me wonder sometimes
but i would feel like it feels to me
that it would be pretty obvious
and if you're a lawyer you'd probably
understand this that if you are going to
be working on a public lawsuit
you're probably going to get a lot of
public backlash they weren't ready for
any of that
i'm not saying that's good if i would
say no posting phone numbers that's
pretty abhorrent
however it feels more like they probably
left because they saw the case was
meritless rather than just like oh we
got death threats so we decided to
walk away that's possible too but that's
possible too but that's speculative
more so i would say if if we get the
lincoln project a bunch of news stories
were published saying
you know republican pac that you know
anti-trump republican pac
sure publishes private information
twitter forced the tweet down and then
within a couple days the lawyers put an
official request to leave the case our
only chain of events is this
so i think it's the simple solution is
they were threatened and harassed to the
point where they said we don't want to
be involved anymore sure i guess it's
just surprising that the lord would say
i can't believe my information went
public on one of the most public
lawsuits being followed the world right
now that's
very strange to me there's no other
there's no other issues and how come all
the other
lawyers you know aren't who are not
getting harassed are staying on
why aren't they are the other lawyers
aren't getting harassed at all they're
hard to believe as well
i'm sure that any public name that's on
any of those filings
the lincoln project publishing your
phone number is probably very different
from just being a law firm on one of the
suits possibly
yeah thanks for checking out this clip
from the tim cast irl podcast we do the
show live
monday through friday at 8 pm so come
back to check us out when we go live
don't forget to subscribe hit the like
button hit the notification bell
and we are also available on all podcast
platforms for
free if you want to listen to us there
thanks for hanging out and we will see
you all
next time
you